[Musique]
c'était un échec
c'est une défaite quand on a une défaite
ça m'est arrivé dans ma vie politique il
faut la reconnaître il faut en tirer les
leçons
et puis faut rebondir magazine elle qui
te fait pour s'exprimer
c'est non mais c'est assez bizarre en
finlande la déchéance des chances
politique est menée de lendemain de
régionales il ne changera pas de premier
ministre bonne idée
essayons change pas une équipe qui perd
là il faut changer quoi rien mais
franchement c'est des élections locales
je crois que les français ne se trompent
de moins en moins des élections
contrairement parfois aux responsables
politiques et ils font bien la
différence entre le vote pour un maire
pour un conseiller départemental ou pour
un président de la république je vois
tout d'un coup d'autres al'inverse qui
vous dit c'est pas une victoire
c'est un triomphe ça y est nous sommes
déjà candidat à la présidentielle élu
président de la république et la
majorité actuelle le président c'est
fini pour en examiner entrant là je
pense à xavier bertrand je pense à
d'autres vainqueurs j'ai félicité les
territoires en moquait il y a
aujourd'hui je ne dis pas que c'est fait
mais il ya un possible qui s'est ouvert
avec sept élections régionales et
départementales avec le sentiment que
nous n'avons nous ne sommes plus
condamner cette fatalité d'un deuxième
tour entre emmanuel macron et marine le
pen
ils ont été élus dans un scrutin local
marqué par une forte abstention et pour
l'e3 vous venez de citer avec beaucoup
moins de voix qu'aux scrutins précédents
je considère pas que ça fasse une rampe
de lancement pour une élection
présidentielle c'est un président de la
république hors sol je pense sincèrement
c'est il a grandi à dire hors d'île à
grandir dans un salon il ne connaît pas
la france vient du système bancaire il a
été sponsorisée par les grandes fortunes
qui l'ont fait élire représentants de la
finance emmanuel macron continue depuis
quelques jours a enchaîné les
déplacements sur comme vous avez pour
reprendre votre expression claire cette
france qui gagne
hier à douai et à versailles ce matin au
siège de la banque américaine jp morgan
qui vient de s'implanter ici dans de
nouveaux locaux place vendôme
le débat sur le burqini la burqa maillot
de bain relancé par le maire écologiste
de grenoble eric piolle qui semble en
réalité vouloir autoriser le burkina
faso de plus pas papy fait la révolution
non soyons sympas pas ça non s'il vous
plaît moi j'en fais pas le maire
écologiste de grenoble erik cole sera
candidat à la primaire écologiste prévue
en septembre
je veux aussi un peu au plan local et au
plan national doublé et yannick jadot
sur sa gauche extrême dans le cadre de
la concurrence avec les verts pourquoi
vous parlez que la preuve était de
gauche ou après il va vous traiter de
facho il a fait déjà ça y est parce que
vous avez commencé mais non mais est ce
que je suis c'est une insulte aux
gauchos d'abord je laissais pas des gens
comme ça il nous faut une loi pour
pouvoir aller vers une vaccination
obligatoire des soignants et on a donné
une date on a donné la date de septembre
c'est à dire qu'on se donne l'été pour
que vraiment tout le monde ait eu le
temps de faire son choix et de se
vacciner
après quoi ou ici si la vaccination est
insuffisante nous nous irons vers une
vaccination obligatoire canicule
étouffante qui frappent le nord des
états unis et le canada il fait plus de
46 degrés par exemple à portland presque
48 degrés un peu plus au nord et
commerces les écoles les centres de
vaccination ont par conséquent dû fermer
si vous aviez gagné vous ne voyez pas ça
aux qu'il est méchant mon jeu pas
méchant c'est si vous avez gagné
je suis pas du tout bon c'est vrai nous
allons plutôt rire et bougon ça m'amuse
vous écouter vous aviez gagné on duriez
ça prouve bien qu'il faudra laisser moi
terminer avec cette ourse et ses deux
oursons qui se rafraîchit dans la
piscine d'un habitant de l'état de
colombie britannique